uh welcome back welcome to ramsay in 10.
uh more importantly can i just say a
very special thank you to all the nh
staff again for another extraordinary
week all the effort
and dedication is extraordinary um and
also
an extra special thank you to
well he's a legend and he's become a
legend over the last three weeks
captain tom moore
days away from celebrating 100th
birthday um
sir
you've raised over 23 million pounds
the next time someone tells me about
running half a marathon
an ironman an ultra marathon if they
turn around and say to me i'm too old
for that i'm gonna reference you
nearly a hundred years old and you're up
and down the garden a hundred times to
raise money
but there's something special going on
because this goes to show how special
this country is and the size of the
heart where they donate in the way that
even the people i know
you know that are tied with their
finance are still donating so
this donation is going to you tonight to
say a special thank you and more
importantly
god bless sir now uh should we check to
see where my soup chef is he said he'd
be turning up on time but i think he's
been distracted please where is he
he said he was gonna help me out but
uh
excuse me
hey
hello i just got the wind spoon
oh no really
peppa pig
i'm not going to tell you about the pigs
we are from the back garden no oh okay
now what is oh hello what is that chili
could have been a bit more color on the
old beef there no
okay now we have a new director of
photography that's right um
in fact she started filming at 12. we
should put our braces on
we know as matilda you know as today
let's go to yours
now turn it around say hello to yourself
right okay uh pan down tilly oh my god
yes i'm not making it okay panda panda
right uh mint
okay i've got minced meat a little bit
of cheddar cheese some bacon there okay
a little bit of lettuce tomato an egg
egg is optional onion lettuce and the
buns why are you telling me
why so
i said 10 minutes okay and i got a
little secret i froze those okay little
chillies anything left there like that
freezing because you can grate that in
to sort of make that sort of almost a
little bit more delicious this is
literally just plain minced beef right
timmy are we ready ready to start yes uh
time goes now right first off ten
minutes dad let's go
gas on okay i'm using a grill pan okay
but you can use a frying pan so
uh a grill pan get that on and get it
nice and hot now first off season a
touch of
salt touch it
touch your pepper
now i'm putting an egg in there okay
stay with your tails pan over i'd like
the yolk okay
don't use your hair
hold on it's my burger uh
yolk okay in
now from there okay i wanna just
literally get that chilli
okay
and just grate
that in there
now the secret behind this is just give
it a little bit extra heat okay and when
you grate it like this it sort of
disintegrates a chili pepper pan up it's
me now it's me it's not all about you
it's about food and then look pan down
back down look oh my god
beautiful little chili flakes in there
now come on now from there okay just a
touch of seasoning
now the best thing to do is get your
hands in there
okay and literally shake that
okay now
i said shape it not drop it on the floor
now here's the secret
we've got 10 minutes to make this burger
okay and i've got sort of 75 seconds
gone
if you've got more time than i have
tonight then maybe a little bit thicker
if you haven't then make them nice and
thin so take off
a nice ball okay
almost like a sort of the size of a
tennis ball and then literally
start shaping
those burgers like that
now look
get your hands around
and just literally
place that
on pan down pan down pan down meg i'm
tilling it
down so i'm gonna put literally about
i'd say an inch
in height okay and look what that egg
does that egg
actually makes it a little bit richer
okay now from there quick wash their
hands first time
um
two minutes
ago okay so the cooking time is about
seven minutes okay oh counting it five
cut it very fine oil on okay grapeseed
oil
i've seasoned the burger okay
yeah one yes
and then on
okay now
look at that okay push it down we're
gonna turn it once okay i've seasoned
the meat inside okay
so
from there i want to season the meat
again on top and down to it please
on top
there you go now
turn up the gas
okay
now i love onions i'm a burger okay but
what i don't love
is the raw onion so get your onion
slice
nice and thick okay
down
down
a touch of oil
a touch of salt and pepper on there and
look get those onions on the grill
look at that beautiful
come on seriously
now alongside that what goes wrong with
the burger please chili
burger onions
oh some beautiful
streaky bacon this is a streaky bacon
from that wonderful
butcher
on rock high road now look we're cooking
all this together i want the bacon fat
going in
to the burger i want the flavor the
onions going into the burger and get
that juicy toasted
now whack up the gas
okay
three and a half minutes yes yes yes now
whilst we're cooking the burger
okay literally
pan down for you put down mayonnaise
okay
mayonnaise in
a little bit of pepper
we'll take the salt
and from there
come on oh there it
it's a little touch of heat just as the
mayonnaise okay
mix that up
now you could use mustard in there grain
mustard you could put english muffin
there you put dijon mustard and look at
that really nice spicy selector so let's
run through this
we're done
okay okay chili yes look at that flavor
look at the color little one's coming
out of there okay
but
watch this
watch what oh my lord
okay
here we go
look at those onions
that is not burnt
there's nothing worse
no stop that now the buns
the buns the buns the buns what are you
already sandwiched excuse me sorry the
buns are brioche buns okay high content
butter says be a little bit more richer
so i want to get them toasted so it
takes that weight of the burger get the
buns on and toast those puns but look
we're all in the same pan here now
good news is we're not even halfway yet
we're gonna make this push that down
gently not too hard
and flip that once and once only under
that's still cold there
and look get the color on the burger
from there now
look at my buns
look at that beautiful has a caramelized
bun tilly nearly burnt that is not burnt
stop it let's do it right from there
beautiful now we can start
to orchestrate this amazing burger
now pan down please pan down calm down
and walk uh tell me your puzzling butter
please yeah please
right here we go
now if you like cheese on that burger
here's a little secret
get the cheese little square
of cheese on there okay put that on okay
bring that to
the side
and just to get that cheese melting okay
i take
a little bit of
butter
and i sort of create
a little bit of sort of extra
flavor with the butter underneath and
that's going to give it so much flavor
but look get a pan and put the pan on
and just stick that on top there like
that that will help melt the cheese time
left clean silly how long um you have
got
let's go i'm trying to find your timer
what i'm working five minutes no we've
got four minutes left four minutes
seriously now look at that bacon i've
got a bacon okay juicy color take that
down there
okay
but do me a favor till the pan and get
that bacon fat pan down till you burn
down to me
bake your fat inside
pan up two look at those onions now come
on seriously honestly
they're the kind of onions you see on
that burger van outside butt in the
palace now before they come off a little
bit of seasoning okay and just look
now you can't smell this but the color
of those onions is incredible i'm
telling you come on
three minutes to go from there
they're caramelized young lady how many
times have told me to do it between
caramelized and burnt whoa honestly
should have gone to space savers right
panda panda caramelized onions they are
delicious seriously delicious off and
drain okay
off
and drain
now pan up chills please pan up i'm
already off okay good right lift the lid
off look if you haven't got a pan put a
bowl on top of that but look at the
cheese the cheese starts melting now
that
looks beautiful right
again
on there gasps right
let's start
the process pan down please two minutes
to go base on there right yep
we're running out of time
lettuce first that protects the burger
okay
from there a little slice
time left
watch me let this tomato
oh sugar i forgot the uh spice okay
now build this
baby beautifully okay a little bit of
salt on top of that
now from there i'd like some onions on
there
okay pan down please pan down
look at it already honestly it's like a
vegetarian delight come on how beautiful
is that
plenty for the onions the difference
between grilled onions and raw onions
you'll eat way more grilled than you
will
raw beautiful little seasoning twister
pepper
okay
from there
burger's not quite ready time haven't
gone on hold on a minute and a half left
30 seconds left okay now from there just
literally baste that okay and just
gently push down gently
gently not too much
gently
the bacon
okay gonna get extra crispy
back on
and then from there
i should have made it a little touch
thinner but look away that cheese is
caramelized around that burger now look
that is beautiful before you take that
off
yes
from there
you go on with
a little touch of salt on top of there
take that bacon off
okay
now
touch it's a little bit more in there
problem is now i can't turn that burger
because i'm gonna wait for the
caramelized now you can do this in a
frying pan okay but think of the way we
assembled it okay and think about the
sort of magic involved but
if i turn that round there like that
it's literally going to burn dad yes
sandra says you can do it
thank you
oh man i made the boat oh
[ __ ]
don't put that on it okay
oscar look at his face look
look
oh
[Applause]
and then the onions wait wait wait wait
but look at that fail
oh my goodness me the fibergate were
cool
i mean seriously
okay
first of all
what six where's the windscreen
[Music]
i
i may not have done it in 10 minutes to
be honest that ramsey's already donated
to an amazing cause um i can't wait to
see your burger don't forget to hashtag
me
and more importantly if it's good enough
i'll share it if it's bad enough i'll
still share it now i'm not going to eat
this and i'll give it to the neighbors
next door
[Music]